Quick exec sync. Launch is in two weeks and I want to close out anything still open.
Churn analysis went out last Thursday, as promised. Short version is the annual tier is four points worse than we modelled.
Which brings us back to pricing. We delayed the increase for launch. Does the churn data change that for Q3?
It argues for delaying further, honestly. If the annual tier is already churning above forecast, a rise makes that worse before it makes revenue better.
I'd add that the migration damaged trust with exactly the accounts on annual plans. Those are the ones we'd be raising on.
So we're now talking about not raising prices at all this year. That's a bigger decision than delaying to Q3.
It is, and I don't think we should take it in a fifteen minute sync. I'd want the revenue modelling in front of us.
Agreed. Decision for today: pricing stays flat through launch, and we schedule a proper session on the annual tier before end of Q2.
I'll pull the account-level churn split so that session has something concrete to work from.
On migration, the rehearsal environment scoping is done. It's about eleven thousand a year to keep a production-sized restore available.
That's cheaper than I expected. Put it in the budget conversation rather than deciding it here.
Will do. Rollback tooling landed this sprint too, so the four hour problem should not repeat.